đường buồn xử hơi quen,
nó sẽ nước bây giờ cũng như trên quá đồ.
Đưa nè em, anh có thù muốn vô,
sợ chương nhạc, sợ phát, tạm ra.
Bông gặp ngày xưa đi từng đạm ngoài.
Mà vào đạm trong,
phía đường xã rất khó đi,
thởi mở chú mùi et đi mặt có thể.
Với đi cạnh rất là đẹp.
Un người thì hình thì á.
Trong đề thì sợ rất đạo đạo đạo thì chúng tôi,
một quốc hồ khí của thể tích là hai chắc bố người xung đi này khỏi.
Vì xâm trong xin lạnh,
có quyết tâm là ký như quen.
Bây giờ năng bố biết tâm là hai quyết bố,
bây giờ năng thái bố,
sẵn đi đặt bố,
ám xuất,
bên trong bằng hạm xuất bên ngoài.
Vì bí tâm là một trong bí bố,
bà càn,
bỏ qua mặt xác,
có ai quá trị làm nhiệm.
Ở đây quá trị làm nhiệm.
Đây, rịch truyền,
bí tâm xam chái hai xanh đi mẹ.
Thì tắt dụt một lực bằng ngon nhỏ.
Được biết,
năng bài tróng người là biết đây là bài toán về khí,
lý tưởng,
lý quán lệ quả trị,
đặc nhiệm.
Quán trị làm nhiệm thì ai có nhiệm.
Vì bó qua mặt xác,
bỏ qua mặt xác,
bỏ qua ai ai ai ai.
Được,
tâm đăng hông bài khí lý tưởng,
khí lý tưởng người quán lý tưởng bà thông số.
Ám xuất,
Kể tích bánh yệt tổ trị tổy,
bà bây giờ mài nó hỏi lực.
Được,
tâm được nhiệm cái tâm ký lịch truyền,
thải sống như mẹ.
Vậy là có côn tức mổng qua lệm,
ạ.
bỏ a xuất,
ló là,
ám xuất.
3 bằng app look
Chia chong
Chia